Let's see the answers. Buy more powerful
hardware. Yes. That could certainly help, but it
will not provide unlimited scalability. What about optimizing
the software? Yes. That could certainly also help.
But that, will not provide unlimited scalability either.
Copy and run software on more servers. Well,
normally, software cannot just be copied, and run
on more servers. To be able to run
on more servers, you typically have to change
the software, so this option is also an alternative.
In fact, if you can change your software to
run on more servers, you are starting to work
with the scalable architecture. This is because the capacity
will not be limited by the hardware you use,
or how much you can optimize your software. When
you need to scale, you can add more servers.